generally speaking people who have done
nothing wrong don't ask for immunity in
order to testify or to talk to
investigators our old friend alex jones
is asking for immunity if he is to
discuss his role and knowledge related
to the january 6 trump riots it is not a
good week for alex jones bankruptcy but
a bankruptcy that may be calculated to
try to shield assets from people he's
ultimately going to have to pay money to
which lawyers say isn't even going to
work and now alex jones wants immunity
new york times report alex jones reaches
out to justice department about trump
riot interview the effort by the trump
ally to get an immunity deal is the
latest sign of progress in the
investigation which recently brought on
a well-regarded prosecutor
uh the federal investigation into
efforts to overturn the election seems
to gain traction justice department has
brought in a new prosecutor alex jones
the host of the conspiracy driven media
outlet infowars and a key player in the
pro-trump trump to stop the steel
movement is in discussions about an
agreement to detail his role in the
rally
through his lawyer joan said he has
given the government a formal letter
conveying his desire to speak to
prosecutors the lawyer norm pattis
maintained jones had not engaged in any
criminal wrongdoing that day
as a condition of being interviewed
jones
has requested immunity from prosecution
now the reason they're giving is he
distrusts the government
so weird to believe
alex jones
believes and knows that he did nothing
wrong
but he is so distrustful of the
government he thinks if he talks to them
they will find some crime to pin on him
anyway
and um
that's why he wants immunity
while convincing federal prosecutors to
grant him immunity
could be an uphill climb for alex jones
his discussions with the justice
department suggest that the
investigation could be gathering
momentum
two weeks ago another prominent stop the
steel organizer ali alexander an
associate of jones revealed he got a
subpoena from a grand jury
that is seeking information on a broad
swath of people rally planners members
of congress others close to trump about
what happened on that day
this is absolutely fascinating now again
in general innocent people don't try to
get immunity as a condition of speaking
to investigators alex jones wants us to
believe it's not because he believes he
did something wrong it's because he
believes they are going to sandbag him
because he doesn't trust the government
now
as in that i spoke to some investigators
about this and they said listen
anyone can always say
they're going to try to find something
to pin on me but that in general
they genuinely if they don't think alex
jones is the top dog right you you want
to use people to get the top dogs that's
the general idea here that why would you
talk to alex jones first and even
consider immunity if you thought he was
at the top no that's the guy you want to
take down so they believe there's people
higher up than jones
if that's the case
you want to genuinely
have a goodwill working relationship
with the witness because that's how
they're going to tell you ideally
everything or everything you want to
know
so
only the most paranoid person would
think
even in a cooperation agreement they're
going to try to sandbag me it it just
doesn't really make sense it's not
typically how these investigations work
is it possible that they want to charge
alex jones sure it's possible but if
they're looking to him as a cooperating
witness to get bigger names they're
they're not going to deceptively sandbag
him they might be up front and say we're
not ready to give you immunity because
we actually do think you might have
committed crimes but let's talk
that's the way things can go that way
for sure but the idea that uh out of
nowhere they're gonna sandbag him with
the most serious charges it's just not
to the advantage of investigators if
they want to get what they think is the
most valuable stuff from alex jones now
at the other side of this
um
is that
this all could be a stall tactic
we've also talked about and we talked
about yesterday that in general there's
lots of people on the periphery of the
justice department investigation and the
january 6th investigation into what is
going on what happened and who was
involved with january 6th and with a
midterm election coming up and with um
an attorney general in merrick garland
who is of questionable conviction when
it comes to really prosecuting
wrongdoing um of higher-ups when it
comes to the january sixth circumstances
running out the clock and stalling as
much as possible isn't a crazy idea so
it is not an illogical strategy for alex
jones to ask for immunity even if he
knows he's not going to get it simply as
a delaying tactic to say i am willing i
am willing but we've got to figure out
immunity first
also remember
that
if he has relevant information
immunity might do more good
than compelling him to testify because
then he'll do what he already did which
is just plead the fifth amendment which
he's constitutionally
able to do there's no there's no
question about that thinking from a
practical investigative perspective you
might end up getting more from giving
him immunity than from just compelling
him to testify because we know what him
and eric trump did they pled the fifth
hundreds of times so
another not great week for alex jones
we will see if he gets immunity
one of our sponsors today is cheese
butter i love this stuff cheese butter
is a delicious gourmet cheese melt that
ingeniously blends
four indulgent cheeses and aromatically
seasoned butter
all the ingredients the cheese the
butter the seasonings are sourced for
the highest quality you can really taste
that this was made with fresh simple
high shelf ingredients nothing
artificial
cheese on bread right i mean come on and
butter on bread
why wouldn't i love cheese butter put it
on french bread sourdough bagels english
muffin jewish rye
pumpernickel
sandwiches grilled cheese burgers baked
potatoes mac and cheese broccoli veggies
cheese butter is a business that
supports the david pakman show support
them their product is really fantastic
it's been a secret recipe in their
family for 50 years
taste it for yourself to really
understand what it's about
i don't think you'll be sorry and you'll
now get 20 percent off when you go to
cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below